okay
let's
do it
[Music]
okay ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
to your absolutely favorite podcast
[Music]
[Music]
what up y'all
[Music]
ripping
welcome
back
doing it so i turned 50 this past
weekend march 12th
let's recap my life
i'm past midlife but you know 50.
you want to live 100 years but it is
what it is someone talk about that
little nba action
and then i want to review this movie i
saw on netflix the adam project but
overall just thank you for being here
yay
[Music]
all right y'all welcome back to riffin
with griffin
uh that's how we doing it
let me turn that down
i don't wanna
don't wanna hear that buzz
man the traveling messed me up just when
you're trying to not be sick but anyways
make sure you subscribe
share and all that stuff make sure you
check me out on twitch which i do that
daily i'll probably probably be doing
that after this but before we start
let's talk about our great new sponsor
of the show
coinbase for a limited time new users
can get 10
in free bitcoin when you sign up today
at coinbase.com
sign up at coinbase.com riffin griffin
for ten dollars in free bitcoin
okay guys yeah what's up um we're live
right now um first of all let me just
say tuesday is gonna be the new day
tuesday is gonna be the new day for
riffing with griffin i used to do it on
mondays but it's just like i'd be
traveling and if i want to do it live or
if i want to be able to like record an
episode and then put it out i want to i
need another day because like i like
yesterday i traveled back from florida
yesterday because i went to west palm
beach florida i'll tell you about that
uh and then my system is all messed up i
can't even use my good mic i had to use
this old mic because i got to figure out
what the hell's going on with
um my system i'm having if anybody out
there those
i need some help
just some questions about because my
focusrite usb
um you know my mixer
i think there's something wrong with the
headphones jack and it's just it's just
so frustrating
i can't hear the sound properly it's
messing me up when i'm gaming it's just
so annoying so hit me up if you uh if
you're into that kind of stuff but once
again thanks for subscribing thanks for
sharing and all you know all that stuff
uh you know
i i appreciate that
so um
50 y'all can you believe it i know i
look delicious 50 years old rachel got
me this great big beautiful 50 card but
you know birthdays are weird for dudes
man
if we're just being honest right and you
get to a certain age where your
birthday's not even important anymore
even with my girl my my birthday is
supposed to be her birthday that's like
you know you know how they get when it's
like oh it's your birthday i have all
these plans for us and you're just like
well i don't sound like something i want
to do on my birthday but it's like you
know it's
it's like when you're due your birthday
becomes your girl's birthday and her
birthday is her birthday you know what i
mean so
it is what it is
i um
so then but here's what happened though
i was like i
wanted to
[Music]
i didn't know what i wanted to do it's
like do i want to have people over and
there isn't a lot of people i'd want to
have over you know it's like i had this
thing with my mom my mom's got dementia
so it's like you know she don't even
remember us my birthday you know what i
mean
so it's like that's tough because that's
my only real family my stepfather's
great shout out to him like he you know
he sent me a card and he makes my mother
call i know that he hey it's eric's
birthday you should call him and so i
appreciate that he did that because she
did call me and but you know it's like
those kinds of things and then you know
then i have rachel and it's the only
other person that's close to me is my
you know he's like a brother to me i
consider him my brother even though it's
not my real brother but you know
rachel don't like them you know they do
so they have like an issue and and so i
wanted him to come by
you know but she's like i don't want to
see him and it's like it's a whole thing
and you know so and then it just you
know then it just became like this thing
where i'm like do i want to
do i want to even deal with this and so
then
you know
you know it's because like you know it's
like do i feel old or did i have like a
midlife crisis type thing where i'm like
oh my god i'm 50 i
i didn't feel none of that you know i
still don't feel that
the only thing i feel is like pressure
to work like i like pressure to retire
like that's what i feel like i feel like
do i have enough money in the bank where
if i stopped working i would still be
able to work i would still be okay you
know that's all i work for now you know
what i mean
uh along with like just enjoying the the
chase
enjoying like i love auditioning and
being up for something and that whole
feeling of like am i gonna get this or
not so i still enjoy that
i don't enjoy traveling uh if i if i had
to stop i i love doing stand-up but the
traveling sucks especially with the
masks and all that [ __ ] but
so you know i travel stand up but that's
where it's become work unfortunately
until i'm there and i'm on stage you
know
so
you know that it's just it's a weird
thing i'm trying to i'm trying to like
describe like how i feel turning 50. i
don't know
um
it's weird you know what i mean
it's weird it's weird it's weird so
yeah you know i'm and this is live so
i'm just contemplating this live with
you chat and people listening right now
you know later on spotify or um
apple music or wherever you get your
podcast thanks for listening and you
guys that are watching on youtube you
should also please subscribe to my
podcast and leave a comment please you
know go on to my apple podcast and leave
a review that really helps me it helps
it helps grow the show so i would
appreciate if you like would do that too
go give me a like give me whatever stars
you want five hopefully and then give me
a little little note that that's uh very
helpful for the show it helps grow the
algorithm too for my uh
audio podcast but anyways
yeah so how do i feel
so last minute i'm still trying to
decide what i want to do you know what i
mean do i want to go do i want to have a
little thing here do i want to just go
to dinner with rachel
uh go to breakfast with my brother i
don't know what i want to do right then
i get a call from my agent and he's like
yo they got a fallout this dude got
covered and he can't go to west palm
beach florida do you want to take the
gig
and then i was like ah this is perfect
so i did it i went to west palm beach i
took the gig and there was something
poetic about it because i've said this
so many times on podcasts and stuff like
interviews radio everywhere i've always
said this i always said
because i was 30 when i decided to
become a professional comedian 20 years
ago i
decided i need to i this is what i
really want to do
and i always used to tell myself it was
because i didn't want to wake up 50
and be like i didn't follow my dreams
i just didn't want to feel that because
you see people that just have failed in
their life and i think most people fail
at the thing that they want to do it's
just it's
a sad fact not everybody succeeds not
everybody
you know people become successful in
other things or they make it work
because we're such an adaptable
creatures but not everybody follows
their dream and and actually
accomplishes it
you know and so i i
i want to take this time i've just
turned 50 and i want to look back in my
career and be like well did i make it
and hell yeah i did i did it
i was on an iconic television show
okay
workaholics
as an iconic character montez
that people still call me montez and
they probably will for the rest of my
life there's people that come up to me
and go yeah i know your name is eric but
you always be montez to me
that's golden man
you know like what a what a fantastic
experience like seven years of my life
doing that show
and just being a part of like history
you know that's like one of those shows
that people will be like that was my
favorite show and so they love it
um
[Music]
and thank you lucid escape for the the
super chat guys you know don't be afraid
to give give your brother a super chat i
appreciate that
and give me some likes too guys make
sure you like subscribe and share
so um
you know working hard so i have
workaholics right
and then i've done you know
then i was like i've been in movies you
know i've been in some i've been in some
movies i've done movies i was i've done
like dramatic work i did like like i'm
dying up here even though we got two
seasons i was really proud of the work
that i personally did on that show and
then i think about like yeah
i've played i've headlined all over the
country i've traveled all over the
country doing stand-up i've traveled all
over the world doing stand-up i can look
back on these 20 years and been like
damn i did all this with following my
dream
i got plenty of money in the bank i'm
not rich but i got money in the bank
that like if i did stop working right
now i would be okay or i would just like
invest in like i'd get a starbucks or
something like i i got enough money to
change my profession and and feel like
i'm okay with it you know what i'm
saying i just i feel like i put myself
in a good
position
so
that's good oh by the way here's mike in
west palm beach uh just with his 1.99
super chat but i think this is the same
guy
oh i should have had it with me right
now so i get a call from the front desk
because mike's in west palm beach i get
a call from the front desk y'all
and they go hey there's a package for
you all right i go okay you know
security brings it up it's a package
there's a nice birthday card on it it's
like one of those funny you just turned
50 birthday cards 50 50 50 you know and
i'm reading i'm like oh this is really
cool because i didn't have a birthday
card cause i was by myself you know what
i'm saying um you know and then the
package i open up the package and it's
adult diapers
adult diapers thank you mike from west
palm beach he gave me a good birthday
card and adult diapers you piece of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
it was funny
it actually was really funny so that's
the only reason i'm bringing it up shout
out to you you made me laugh on my
birthday and you really went out of your
way to do that so you know i got crazy
fans and and that's uh how that happened
so
anyway let's get back to it so you know
workaholics i'm dying up here
murder mystery
uh you know
um
i've been on three really like funny
shows and now what i feel like right now
is happening and i'm still in the mix
last year around this time i booked a
pilot i booked this abc pilot called bl
uh what was it called i forgot how he
put it out of my head because i didn't
it didn't get picked up you know what i
mean so and this year i'm in the works
again guys i'm in the works again for
like a movie and a couple of shows so i
feel like yeah i'm in the business so i
feel like i work 20 years to be a
working actor comedian and i'm doing it
i'm a regular at the comedy store
you know i'm always in the heart of the
lineup there uh you know through the ups
and downs of that place i'm still a
constant you know i have to keep keeping
it fresh because you know all these
funny funny young comics are like on the
scene now
and i and then like i don't want to be
like oh there's the old guy still here i
need to be like no no i'm here because
i'm funny and so that makes me work on
my comedy and like you know keeping it
fresh and relevant and it's like you
know i feel like i did it you know what
i mean i really feel like i did it and
my message to like all of you guys out
there that are like you know i don't
know what you do for a living but is it
the thing you want to do is it that um
you know it's was it your dream have you
made it your dream did you like not
attempt your dream you know like no
matter what it is
did you take a moment you realized ah my
dream is unrealistic but i don't even
know like it's depending on your age and
like where you are in life
don't think anything is unrealistic
until you weigh the pros and cons you
know if you're like a if you're a four
seven white white boy and you're 30
years old you're not gonna make the nba
okay all right so i get it there are
unrealistic like crazy dreams but like
is there a moment that you should take a
moment and think about that let's see i
can't jump i'm i'm slow
uh i didn't go to college to play
basketball so that's out at least give
yourself that like lay out lay out the
process for whatever your dream might be
because you still might be able to
achieve something some things you know
what i mean
so especially if you're young man you
know and i mean when i say young i mean
if you're under 30
if you're under 30 don't think you still
can't accomplish the things you want to
accomplish because there's so many
different outlets now there's so many
different ways to like go to school and
learn a profession there's so many
different like trade things you can get
into there's so many things you can get
experience at so you can get into the
field that you want to get into
you know i don't know but it's like
dream big man dream big and find a way
to make it happen at least attempt it
you know
attempt it
so
um
i don't know i don't know that's just
what i have to say about that so you
know and it's like turning 50. see
another thing for me about this is that
i'm i feel like i've lived a complete
life already and i have 20 years in the
business
50 i feel like i did it let me just but
now i'm actually doing something even
bigger in my life right now i'm about to
get married
whoo and i'm super excited about it
actually uh i've come you know i
i don't know how i was feeling before
the nervous the anxiety and everything
but i'm at a point right now where i
can't wait i love rachel to death she's
the best
and i appreciate her and how she is you
know it's just these kinds of little
things that she does get this car with
all this like you know look at she wrote
inside it all this like you know
really beautiful stuff she wrote to me
and you know just like so she wants to
start a new life and so now i'm in this
process i'm working out you know i'm
getting my workouts in now
uh because i'm trying to like stay
healthy i'm trying to like like actively
being healthy you know like really
trying to be like
all right let me cut back on this than
that and
it's hard man you know when you 50 it's
hard to be like well i can't i shouldn't
eat like this anymore so i'm still
working on the diet part of it
uh really working on that but i don't
also don't want to be a crazy person
where i'm only eating chicken breasts
and that's it it's like hey i want to
live my life too so i'm trying to find
that balance but just working out like a
simple like i do a wrong i have a rowing
machine shout out to hydro i have a
rowing machine and man i feel stronger
and i just feel healthier my poops are
coming out like you know wow you know i
feel like like it i feel like this
exercise that i'm doing it has a lot of
effects on my body that i didn't realize
you know we just need to have going on
and i think about my mom too i know when
my mom was my age she wasn't working out
she wasn't taking care of herself she
just has like this kind of metabolism
like a lot of women in in my mom's
family they just they they just don't
get fat right so when people think oh
well i don't get fat so there's no
reason reason to work out but
look there's two things you got
being healthy
and you got a nice physique
physique health they're not the same
thing even though you do some of the
same things to achieve those things you
know but they're not the same thing and
they also don't necessarily like you
could be have a really great physique
and do other things it don't actually
mean you're healthy you could be doing
some bad stuff to achieve that and it's
not good for you at the same in the same
way you know just because you're not
doing you know just because you physique
doesn't look say bad it don't mean that
you're healthy
so there are so many things about your
heart
uh blood flow
uh you know there's all these things
they're really like my mind
i'm telling you i'm i feel sharper since
i've been working out because as i'm
getting older i feel like i'm like my
sometimes i forget names you know what i
mean like you know what name i forgot i
i kept forgetting for a long time now
meryl streep
you know i would i would forget her name
i would be like oh what was that chick's
name and the devil wears prada i'll be
like oh my god what's her name what's
her name and it would like
it would scare me i was getting scared
because i was like i can't remember this
bitch's name and i'd be like what is her
name and then now it just comes to me
meryl streep anne hathaway you know and
i know it's because of
i know it's because of the working out i
know it's because of getting blood flow
to my brain and truly trying to take
care of myself and so you know i got to
fight off whatever you know
it's i don't know if it's it's even
proven that dementia is uh genetic you
know what i mean um that's
the science on that is iffy um but
i do know that there are things that
cause dementia it's like inflammation
high cholesterol all the things that
like you know it's just one of those
things another thing where obesity you
know
under the branch of obesity the things
that kill you obesity causes heart
disease it causes dementia causes you
know it's all these things that are
because of obesity these things happen
so i'm trying to work on that and so i
suggest you know you you out there do to
do the same thing
uh
you know what i mean and so and then
there's even like i say yeah i see
somebody in the chat yeah there's such a
thing as a bad diet too you know what i
mean there's bad diets there's bad like
you know there's so many things that go
into just but i just
feel some overall exercise
is really important some movement walks
like do these things it really will help
your body and you know and you don't
know this until you're older
that's the second part man you know not
you know
god beauty is wasted on the young
you know what i mean like it's like
if i would have known and i probably did
know but say 20 years ago
i don't know man i just feel like
i've had like many years of being fat
just being like unhealthy
and it's that kind of fat that you look
at me and go you can be in better shape
you know some people look good fat you
know you see them when you go oh that
like that guy's big boned it or whatever
it is like that right you see people
like that and you go i bet you they
could trim up but you look at me
sometimes i've seen pictures of myself
from the past and i just go oh that's
just lazy fat like there's a difference
between lazy fat big boned or just like
you know how there's a there's a certain
fat where you go
and it makes people like you know when
people
people look at you and they and they
criticize you or they like make fun of
you because of your weight there is a
part of it that they're looking at you
and they're saying you know you could do
better like you could look better than
this and it wouldn't be that
hard to like change your diet
add some
add some exercise like i ain't trying to
run a marathon just add a little bit of
exercise and you'd be surprised when you
look at like you just look better which
makes you more attractive not just
because of your physical appearance but
more attractive because you're working
on yourself there's something attractive
about when people
that think that that's part of it too
like when you see somebody who's like
really fit and you go damn and you find
out they're like oh you're 37 or
whatever however the old they are you
know especially when they're older and
years you go damn good for you because
in your mind you're thinking you know
what it takes
you know how hard that is and you admire
that they're doing that and when people
don't do that you don't admire it it's
not attractive
you know like i wish you would talk
about things in those terms instead of
just always being like you know oh
body positivity and body shaming and all
this kind of nonsense man sometimes i
think it's nonsense
i have some jokes i'm gonna start
working on right now and i guess i can
just talk through it with you guys right
now as i think about it i saw this video
of this sort of like middle-aged you
know militant feminist okay now listen
just like how you have like let's say
you're a democrat and you're like a
moderate democrat and you have like the
fringe far left democrat that are just
just like you find that but that [ __ ]
feminism has the same kind of spectrums
i feel like you know uh i have no
i have no issue with being with people
being a feminist i think men are
feminists too i think i have some
feminist qualities i you know my mom my
mom was my hero and she she showed me
that women can work hard and they can
achieve a lot you know
so you know what i mean so anyways
there's a i saw this video on instagram
so there but there is a certain sort of
militant feminist and you and you all
know what they look like this is the one
i'm talking about it's the one that's
like late 30s early 40s ish
you could tell that she
like was never one of the pretty girls
she may have been she may have been all
right you know what i mean but like
not one of the
bad [ __ ] you know what i'm saying so
she's still got some bitterness there
and she does two things now
one when their options run out all of a
sudden they start using patriarchy in a
sentence every every three days you know
the ones that the patriarchy becomes a
thing what's a patriarchy and so you go
okay here we go and they also like to
chastise young women
one of those you know one of those it's
always like you young women you don't
know that you know
and then they blame ben for everything
you know i did the one that like like
this is the sentence i'm trying to
challenge when they say
men have unrealistic expectations of
beauty
all right that's the sentence y'all
unrealistic
expectations of beauty
i i take exception to that now in the
80s and 90s how about this pre-internet
pre-internet
pre-smartphones okay
pre-internet pre-smartphones
um
yeah
you uh
you know you know what was our what was
our how did we see
pretty chicks
how did we see beautiful women
we saw them in movies we saw them in
magazines
we saw them in tv shows
that was where we saw
this
quote-unquote unrealistic expectations
of beauty that's where we saw it
and yes hollywood was run by men
hollywood you know so you could blame
men for everything you could just be
like well men are the ones that you know
the patriarchy is in charge and they're
the ones that put women in movies and
then you know you cut youth all through
the 80s and 90s and now you have like
harvey weinstein and you have those
kinds of things again all the me too
moving has exposed how terrible some men
are
you know about like you know okay so you
have all that but now we're in a state
where it's
we have the internet
and we have
things like instagram
so when i hear somebody say to me
that we have an unrealistic expectation
of beauty like men have an unrealistic
okay y'all know rachel you see rachel if
you know rachel rachel's a beautiful
she's a beautiful woman okay
because i like all of rachel's pictures
my algorithm is full of beautiful women
so when you go to
so when you go to instagram and you just
you just in the search area
this
all your sort of like things you like
come up so they'll be like for me it'll
be like dogs food
marvel stuff and a lot of beautiful
women so like if i click on one of these
beautiful chicks right here right
and then you just start scrolling up
oh there's another one
oh there's another one
oh there's another one
wait there's another one hold on another
one
another one
you just keep scrolling wait
another one another just random chick
wait here's another beautiful one oh
listen you know what i mean it's just
guys it goes on
and on
and on
so when i look at the internet
and i look at just instagram who is full
of regular people
i start to go
maybe it's not that unrealistic
you know
it's actually very realistic it's
actually like oh you know what
um
it's like
it's like uh
you're acting like
there aren't beautiful women in the
world it's only the ones that are on
magazines and tv and and everybody
should be like you need to look for a
regular chick you know what i'm saying
because regular chicks are how what real
chicks look like but then when i go on
instagram it looks like nah
there's actually
a lot
of
very attractive women who are like are
they doing this for men
is it is are we
making them put this out are we the
reason that there's so many beautiful
women like showing off how beautiful
they are
at all different ages
you know not even just young you know
you see a lot of good-looking women in
their 30s and 40s and they're all on
instagram showing so i mean i'm just
saying
can you is it just is it is it realistic
i think it now it looks pretty realistic
so this unrealistic expectation of
beauty looked pretty pretty realistic
when you just look on instagram alone so
i don't know man
when i do it in my stand up i'm gonna
make it funny you know what i mean so
um
anyways you know and then now i'm seeing
some like really like
nonsense in the chat
so
you know i don't understand why people
think it's okay to
you know
you know say mean [ __ ]
to people you know what i mean
you know what i mean i i don't get that
like
like people think that and i talked
about this last week on my other podcast
you know people think that they're
allowed to be
that they're allowed to be mean like
this idiot in my chat right now who's
gonna be off my page forever
he said he's saying to me you have to
let people state their opinion
okay
and i'm giving you my opinion of your
opinion
so you have to let people state
their opinion
on your opinion
you think that you could just say
whatever the hell you want
and then everybody's supposed to be like
okay
i have no opinion on your opinion that's
how it works bro
you have opinion i don't like because
you're saying something rude about my
friends that's not an opinion okay
that's you being an [ __ ]
so in this situation
i don't want your [ __ ] [ __ ]
around
my thing
this is my thing
like can i go into your house
and just start talking [ __ ] you'd be
like even if it's true if i go into your
house and be like hey yeah your floor is
dirty what is this that art looks stupid
even if it's all true i'm in your house
you have the right to be like yo get out
i why are you here
it's like constructive criticism or like
an opinion about something that you go
okay thank you for your opinion i
disagree with it but when you're just
going out of your way to be mean
i'm like
bye
you know what i'm saying
like i don't need you around me
that's what i'm saying i gotta i don't i
don't get that
this ain't about being salty this is
about like
what like
i don't know
it or or how about
say something funny
like the guy sent me a 50 year old he
sent me a birthday card and he sent me
adult diapers and i thought it was
hilarious and i'm telling you about it
some of y'all
on the chat
you're not funny
we're not laughing at you we're just
like oh that was kind of mean
you know what i mean so then it's just
go all right
you got to go so i don't know
anyways i don't know dude
but like
anyways
back to my point
i think that when you go but i think
that i think that we have to stop saying
this thing about unrealistic
expectations of beauty because they're
they're they're pretty realistic
uh you know what i mean i think they if
you know if you're some if you're some
chick who like doesn't look like some of
these chicks and you're just like you're
telling them hey
you know that's not always going to be
like that well instagram disagrees
because instagram was like no no
actually uh there's actually a lot of
like like a lot like
millions like like
not like a lot like oh there's a hundred
thousand or a thousand out of what no no
from the looks of instagram
it looks like
it looks like there's plenty of there's
plenty of good looking people of all
ages male and female and so when you're
sitting here
when you're sitting here criticizing
people for like
i don't know what you mean you know it's
like we're all kind of lit we're all
shallow in our own way and sometimes i
feel like
like
these these sort of like
this kind of woman i'm talking about
because i saw this video of this like
lady she was like going in about the
patriarchy and men's unrealistic
i wonder who she's going for because
every dude has a friend who's about
quantity
who who like and i don't want to say
quantity over quality but it's like
quantity sometimes it is quantity over
quality but it's also quantity over like
the the base things that we think people
are looking at like how someone looks
sometimes i have a friend who's into
chicks for like
so many different reasons no matter how
they look
okay
he can be like yo dude she got a garden
i'd be like what oh yeah man i went into
her place chick ain't a looker but be
like oh man she she make her own salads
man you don't even know you ever had a
woman make you a salad from her own
garden
and then you like what and that's his
reason but he ain't a looker either
my friend he ain't the most attractive
dude in the world right
so
what i'm saying to like these women who
are talking about unrealistic
expectations of beauty i bet there's a
dude out there that wants to get with
you but you ain't talking about him
you want leonardo dicaprio to be like
hey you have different expectations of
beauty like you need to get with me
like nah [ __ ] it don't work like that
like there's someone out there for
everyone but we are all looking at we're
all looking up we're all like oh i want
somebody that looks like that and i want
that person to like me
but there's a dude that's sitting right
next to you or below you who was like
i'm down to be with you but you're too
busy criticizing the people that you
want to be with
it's a weird thing man it's a weird
thing
but i don't know i'm working on it
and uh
i would turn this into funny material
[Laughter]
uh so be ready for that guys be ready
for that
all right guys coinbase uh
love coinbase uh coinbase is now a
sponsor of the show
um you know my first experience was
coinbase was like it was like a few
years back when like litecoin and
everything just sort of blew up and i
didn't know what it was and you wanted
something simple something easy to uh
maneuver through the
cryptocurrency
ocean and coinbase was so easy and the
best one i still got my coinbase account
even before they became a sponsor this
reason why i was like oh yeah i love be
some coinbase
so if you you know if you're following
the cryptocurrency and you're trying to
like maneuver through it and you know
you don't know what the hell is going on
coinbase is a good place for that if you
you know you're looking for you know
um to level up your financial profile
it's always good to diversify
why not crypto currency backed up by the
world's leading investors coinbase keeps
your profile safe secure while you're
adding crypto into the mix
and that's what i did
so
they offer profile management and
protection which is important because
you know a lot of us don't know what the
hell crypto is our money safe is this
safe so coinbase is the place for that
because they offer like i said they
offer management and protection learning
resources on their mobile app and you
can trade securely and monitor your
crypto all in one place millions of
people over a hundred countries trust
coinbase with their digital assets so
for a limited time new users can get ten
dollars in free bitcoin when you sign up
today at coinbase.com
riffin griffin sign up at coinbase.com
for 10 in free bitcoin the offer is for
a limited time only so be sure to sign
up today that's coinbase.com
written
griffin
okay y'all
and we back
you know let me just reiterate again
okay this ain't about the guys guys
i just want you to understand something
free speech
does not mean there are zero
consequences to your speech
this is what i take exception to
i don't take exception to
what people say
so per se
it's the attitude that comes behind it
the the sentiment by
the sentiment is what pisses me off the
sentiment of thinking you can come on
somebody's
instagram their their their facebook
their their youtube live
and say something out of pocket
and not expect a out-of-pocket response
and then and then and then be mad at
the out-of-pocket response
with
hey
i should be able to say whatever i want
i mean that that sentiment is what
really ticks me off
it's not these like
clownish
words or you know you know what i mean
like
y'all [ __ ] ain't funny it's
like i'm a professional comedian you
know what i mean like y'all don't have
it in you most of you don't have it in
you to make crowds of people
laugh you don't got it in you so i
understand that so i am mad at you that
you're not funny you know what i mean i
look at you you know what i'm saying
it's all good but like
don't be out of pocket with your thought
process that's what that [ __ ] is
anyways
and thank you for all the birthday
wishes i really appreciate that i got a
really lot of uh
greatly great birthday i you know even
though i was out of town i spoke to
rachel a lot and i was like oh man i
felt special
that's what's great about birthdays you
have this one day where people make you
feel special you know and when you're
sort of a public figure it's the one day
that people are leaving their troll [ __ ]
behind and they're sending you a lot of
like great messages and i just
um i really i i uh appreciate all of
that and even now in the chat i
appreciate
you know all that
you know what i mean so it's all good
you know what i'm saying
like here's a guy that's trying to be
funny you should sue mr potato head for
for likeness
i mean it's kind of funny i mean like i
have a mr potato head glass like i don't
it doesn't bug me you know rick glassman
bought me a funny mr potato head mug i
have it over there for in my podcast
stuff you know what i mean so like you
know that's one of those ones where you
go that's harmless you know what i mean
you know it's like but you know
it's like you don't know the guy's
intent it's like are you trying to be
funny
are you trying to get under my skin you
know what i'm saying intent is important
for these things
like with my friends like when i'm with
andrew and bobby oh my god we say some
terrible things to each other but i know
them and so it's like we know the intent
you know it's like you know what i'm
saying so that's all it is it's like a
stranger doesn't know what you're trying
to say
you know that's how things get taken out
of context that's actually what's wrong
with the internet is because you know
people tweet things and in their mind
they know their whole thought process
they know where they're coming from but
it's hard to express like
hey i mean well
in 140 characters you know what i'm
trying to say it's like it's sometimes
it that gets lost so you you do got to
give people like the benefit of the
doubt you know what i'm saying so
i don't know who knows you know what i
mean but you know it it it it it is it
is what it is you know what i'm saying
so you just you just go with it you know
you know what i mean
like sometimes people just don't
understand like here's a guy that
clearly doesn't understand he's saying
you're so sensitive
yeah we're all sensitive
like
what
if if if you put your life on the
internet like as much as i have and i
start talking about you
[ __ ] you're gonna be sensitive too
like it's so funny like people like that
are like you know on their on their
phone like little cowards saying things
don't realize that like we know nothing
about your life to like hit you with
things we're i have no pr hey we're all
sensitive everybody's sensitive i have
no problem with being sensitive i'm
sensitive to like i said
people's intent i'm sensitive to
um
are you like like in my mind i'm like is
this guy trying to be an [ __ ] or is
he trying to be funny like that's
sensitivity i got no problem with being
sensitive like if you think that that's
if you think that that's an insult if
you think that that's a put down
guys listen to me right now don't let
anybody make you feel bad for being
sensitive
sensitive people change the world you
know you're sensitive when you care
about animals and the environment you're
sensitive when you care about the
homeless you're sensitive when you care
about your loved ones you're sensitive
when you care about your profession when
you're trying to
when you're trying to like be better at
something or that's sensitivity so
ain't nothing wrong with being sensitive
you know what i mean
it's just um it's just about how you um
sensitivity is about how you weaponize
it
that's what's wrong with sensitivity
it's like it's okay to be sensitive
about things it's how you express it or
it's how you uh you know
if you let it get you like too upset or
you let it get you um
you know
you know what i mean
when you that's when sometimes you get
out of pocket because you like too
sensitive you know you're like you let
your sensitive you weaponize your
sensitivity you know for me it's like
that's what i do i i do it on stage i
mean
this this is how i perform it fuels my
performance you know when i complain
about something it's like it's funny
that people laugh so that's all part of
my thing i'm on a podcast right now i'm
performing i'm performing so i'm like
you know doing the thing that i need to
do you know what i mean so it's like
it's like these idiots you don't get it
you know what i'm saying this is part of
it you know what i mean so i'm like i'm
doing my thing and then i got some [ __ ]
on here being like oh this guy is
sensitive it's like
yo dude i this is part of it you know
what i mean but whatever
um okay
we did that
thanks again for the birthday wishes
thanks again for the super chats y'all
coming in strong today with the super
chats thank you matt day i appreciate
that man appreciate you brother
um
[Music]
all right let's talk about let's get
into a little bit of nba all right so
you know i like talking about oh you
know what let me put a little thing here
for this
at stream marker all right so i love the
the talking about the nba um
so oh let's go down to this yeah so
you know kevin durant and james harden
they had they had their game you know
they had the game against uh nets played
the sixers and the nets beat the [ __ ]
out of the 76ers and
this is something that like
here's the thing
kevin durant is a phenomenal talent
probably the best player in the league
okay he got the talent to do that
i think his body's gonna let him down
but i hope it doesn't
like i hope he goes on to achieve his
ultimate goal because the dude is
freaking phenomenal okay
but we'll see if he can stay on the
court right that's his thing
i think he's overcome
his
moments
where when he his earlier moments in
like oklahoma city where he look look he
choked he choked into finals against
lebron
uh you know he didn't against golden
state when they were up 3-1
he didn't get it done you know what i'm
saying didn't get it done all right
then he went to golden state and i think
being in that system and not having all
that pressure i think i think you know
and then facing lebron again i think he
overcame that so now the dude's a killer
you know what i mean
dude dude's a killer now so we'll see if
uh
you know
we'll see what happens in in the
playoffs i hope they get rid of that
stupid vaccine mandate in new york so
kyrie irving can play it don't make any
sense that the dude could go to the
stadium but he can't play it don't make
it make any sense that unvaccinated
players can be on the visiting team and
they can play but he can't play like
whoever the idiots are that came up with
that man
it's like
it don't make any sense to me
mind-blowing so i want to see the best
go up against the best so it would be
great to see
what kyrie irving and kevin durant can
do together
all the time on the court home and away
games
deep into the playoffs let's hope
he can stay healthy
and win a championship because that'll
take the monkey off his back
and there are people that don't think he
has a monkey on his back i personally
think he does i think it was weak going
to golden state
but this is a way for him to like win a
championship
and i hope ben simmons doesn't play i
just want to see kevin durant
and kyrie irving do it with the team
that they have
that would be great
right
i just hope one i hope he can stay
healthy
and i hope that kyrie can stay healthy
because he's another one that gets hurt
all the time in big moments
so let's hope they can stay healthy and
then they face
you know whoever they face now in terms
of james harden this dude don't got it
man
like
how many times is he gonna disappear in
big moments
so until he does it we gonna think he
can't
period
if he would have played better
in that championship against the the
cleveland
first time when they played lebron no
i'm sorry miami
if he if he would have played better off
the bench they could have won that
series okay but he didn't
he's been small in big moments for 10
years
hopefully
he can get it together because it would
be nice to see an eastern conference
final of sixers nets
and everybody's playing great
but i don't know man
and personally
i actually think it's unf like they need
to let kyrie irving play in all the
games because it's actually unfair
it's actually an unfair advantage that
he gets to rest as much as he gets to
rest
and everybody else they don't get to
they gotta play every three days
he playing one coming in a hundred
percent coming in like
fresh off you know where however he just
needs to take care of his body like i
wish all the players got that kind of
rest
then we'd see better games we'd see
better performances
it's actually unfair if you really think
about it that's my opinion of that we'll
get back to that another time when we're
talking about uh
the thing you know and somebody's asking
me what do i think about the play-in
tournament
i like to play in tournament actually i
think it inspires these other teams to
play for something
you know what i mean
like i personally think that
um
i think that they should like so you
have the play-in tournament right
i think that
they should they should add to it i
think that the bottom teams
so like the bottom four teams in the
league towards the end of the season
instead of having a draft lottery
they should play for the number one pick
like they should have a team they should
have a tournament
for
draft position
that'd be dope then they would still be
like oh come on we gotta play hard you
know what i mean
and then they get bonuses or something
you know what i mean incentivize them to
make the regular season
uh more important but i think the
playing tournament has made the regular
season super important i just don't
think the seventh seed should be in the
playing tournament i don't like that
because like you seventh you in
you're not the last so you have you you
you're seventh and you have potential to
not make the playoffs i don't like that
but
anyways
so that's my little nba talk for now so
now i want to talk about this movie that
i saw on
netflix i saw this movie on netflix you
all know i love
reviewing movies even though people talk
trash about it all the time
uh i saw this movie the atom project
ryan reynolds mark ruffia
roofie i said mark ruffio
i get nick oh by the way everybody was
criticizing me last week about
all my pronunciations of people's names
like robert
i i kept calling him patterson whatever
his name is you know who the hell i'm
talking about i don't know how to say
his right name right okay
um
but it's what's his name from the
avengers mark what how do you say his
name roof roof
it's not it's not rufio what how come i
what i forgot ruffalo mark ruff is it
ruffalo whatever jennifer gardner and i
think the little kid's name is walker
scobell
zoe saldana and katharina kerner
um
i saw this movie and all right so first
of all let's talk about
uh ryan reynolds ryan reynolds is in a
groove right now where he knows he knows
how to be ryan reynolds in movies and he
is literally ryan reynolds in every
single movie he does
every single movie he does he's ryan
reynolds okay
and
it's like a wisecracking
you know secret agent type guy and he's
always kind of sometimes the underdog
but he's good looking and he's like you
know you know what i mean and he has a
way of like down playing that's like the
superhero that's the that's the the this
this thing that he does
i think he does it pretty good okay
um he does he does it pretty good and at
this point now like the first time i
ever saw him
like be like super duper annoying was in
blade three i don't know anybody's ever
seen blade three but ryan reynolds was
terrible like i hated every second he
was on the screen in blade three
but and then
then cut to deadpool where he figured it
out i think a lot of it was because it
was voice over probably you know what i
mean and they kind of like but he
figured out his groove he figured out
his performance and so now he's deadpool
in every single movie you know what i
mean
and he's been he's been in some really
fun netflix movies man you guys should
check some of them out they're actually
you know because because he he got
enough funny
and he's good looking and he could also
be a badass which is like i like that
mix
uh thank you sonny boy williamson for
the super chats you're the best um
so cut to now you have this thing called
the atom project and in the atom project
time travel so it's a show about it's a
movie about time travel and uh
um you know
he has to go back in time to like stop
some bad stuff from happening because
somebody else changed the timeline it's
one of those timeline things and then
you know in this in their time in their
uh universe they've explained that
they've explained that like you know if
you
die in your timeline
yeah you know uh it's something you know
you you explode or something like that
and you can only be in one timeline at
it like you can only be there's only one
true timeline so they have this kind of
convoluted explanation for time travel
that i accepted they explained the
science and i was like okay i'll go with
that i accept it you know time travel
was a tough thing to uh to do
um and so he goes back and he sees his
younger self played by this kid walker
skobo skobel i think is his name i hope
i'm saying that right this kid is
fantastic man
and as a performer myself i feel like
what they they worked on it and i really
appreciated that like the kid took on
ryan reynolds mannerisms and ryan
reynolds took on the kids mannerisms so
you believed it unlike shazam i don't
know if you guys ever saw the shazam
movie terrible because these two actors
they're not acting like each other so
you didn't believe that he was the same
person in this movie i
i got a sense that they were the same
person the kid was great he was so funny
and like you know what i mean i love
when kids are when a kid is a good actor
and he can deliver some sarcastic lines
and this kid was perfect
and you know it's a good action movie
but let me tell you the thing that's
really great about
uh adam project it's touching as hell
like
you're going cr like if you're i'm
sensitive you know as you guys know you
talk [ __ ] about me on the chat all the
time how substituted i am i am sensitive
i cried a couple times in this
there is some great father-son touching
moments where you really gonna feel it
there's some great touching moments
between him and zoe saldana where like
you know i believed their love story i
it was just it was great i mean it was a
really enjoyable movie it's worth the
watch it really is it's worth the watch
everybody was good you know it's just
one of those like simple stories that
they executed well with some great
performances
um
yeah man it's uh
it's uh it it's really good uh and i
think every single person gives you a
moment where you just go like you know
you find yourself being like well that
was really touching like
i was over there like i'm not crying
you're crying you know what i mean so i
do give uh i do give a bunch of woo-woos
to adam project i think it's worth
watching and you should check it out
[Music]
anyways guys um
that is riffing with griffin for this
week let me look i'm by myself so i
gotta go get my uh i gotta get my music
on for you guys
all right so once again
new riffing with griffin day is gonna
now be tuesdays so check wait let me get
off this screen so check check me out on
tuesdays
um
you know
whiffer will griffin will now be on
tuesdays so make sure you share
subscribe i appreciate you guys being
here and uh
make sure you follow me on twitch eric
griffin gaming too
and check me out jenna jen is back we
got a new episode coming out soon and
we're doing a lot of different type of
content like i'm going to san diego to
do some shows i will be in san diego at
the grand comedy club in escondido so
make sure you go check me out there this
weekend 18th and 19th um
and then i'm coming to i'm coming to lol
in san antonio and i'm also come to the
houston improv check out my website for
that and genderjet we're doing a lot of
like road stuff too so it's not just uh
you know
we're doing a lot of stuff okay so check
that out and also check me out on king
and the sting
uh i think i'm gonna be on this week's
episode of king and distinct so check me
out on that i'm probably gonna be on
like two episodes a month while they're
doing their patreon thing which i
explained on my podcast so check me out
there too so it's jenna jen king of
sting riffing with griffin
uh i appreciate you and once again shout
out to rachel for this beautiful card my
beautiful fiancee we're getting married
in june so she wrote me like this
beautiful stuff so shout out to her
and uh shout out to you guys for being
here and once again thanks for the super
chats thanks for the likes thanks for
the shares help me grow the show y'all
and make sure you check me out on apple
uh podcast make sure like i said please
go to apple podcast and like put a
review on there for me because it helps
me grow the show i appreciate you guys
and thanks for listening and i'll see
you next week
[Music]
me
[Music]